[Music]
it's a lot of nerves but I'm really
excited after three years of having been
here and going through nursing school
especially through the pandemic has been
a difficult time but after all our hard
work I'm excited to see where we're all
going to be going over the next couple
years
[Music]
incredibly exciting just seeing everyone
out here being dressed in discounts
feels like all the hard work was worth
it
[Music]
I don't really know how to express like
all the emotions I'm feeling like
everything I've been to in the last four
years at Yale how hard the last two
years were and finally be here I feel
sort of overcome with just emotions
really happy
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign